翻訳: Mako Tanaka
校正: Hiroko Kawano
今 現在東京の学習塾で教師をしております
小須田悠と申します
今 自分の会社の中で広げているものが —
この「夢応援面談」というものを広げています
あまり難しく考えなくていいと思います
ただ単に子供達と
夢の話をたくさんしようという
そんな簡単な話です
夢応援面談 聞くのは３つだけです
３つだけの質問で夢が引き出せます
まず １つ目
夢はありますか？って聞きます
そうすると 「夢ありますよ僕 」っていう子
何人かいます —
結構いると思います
例えば サッカーが大好きな
中学校２年生の男の子
この子の夢 サッカー選手なんじゃなくて
バイエルンミュンヘンかレアルマドリードに
入団したいっていう夢です
で その夢を聞いたときに
僕がしたことは
じゃあ どうやって入ろうか
いつ入団するっていう話をしました
その子と話したときには
例えば今中学校２年生なので
高校サッカーをするのか
大学サッカーをするのか
Jリーグまで行ってから
バイエルンに行くのか
それとも 中学校を卒業したら
もうバイエルン行っちゃえばいいんじゃないか
っていう話もしました
まあ彼のサッカー
実際にしてるとこ見たことないんで
わからないんですが
でも僕自身は本気で
バイエルン入団できると思ってます
まあこんな風に夢がある子 いますが
「夢ないよ」っていう子もいます
その子に次にする質問 ２つ目です
昔はありましたかっていう質問をします
で それに続けて 僕自身の話なんですが
先生はね １番最初の夢は
忍者になることだったんだよって言うと
まあ「え なにそれ？」みたいな
（笑）
「ああ だったらあったかもしれない」って
話をしてくれます
で １人いるんですが
中学校３年生の男の子です
昔はね 建築士になろうと思ってたんだけど
やめちゃったんだよね
やめた理由は
建築士の試験が難しいって聞いたから
で その男の子
なんで建築士になろうと思ったのって言うと
ちょっと力仕事は得意じゃないけど
地図に残る仕事がしたいんだ
だったら 建築士になればいい
どうやったらなれるんだろうねって
一緒に話しました
近道ってあるのかなっていう話もしました
それで２人で探していったところ
日本大学に入ると試験が通りやすい
という話を探しました
なので この子と一緒に
じゃあ 日本大学に入れる高校を探して
その高校に入ればいい
という話に繋がっていきました
で 昔はありましたか？の質問にも
「いや なかったですね」って
言う子 いるんです
その子に対する３つ目の質問
それが 今ハマっていることとか
楽しいことってありますか
やって楽しいことってありますか？
という質問をします
そうすると
ちょっとずつ出てくる子 いるんです
まあハマっていることくらいは
あると思うので
いると思います
すごく引っ込み思案
もうほんとに人と話すのが不得意な
人見知りの小学６年生の女の子がいました
出会ったときには もう本当に
「はい 」「うん わかった」
「うん さようなら」
くらいしか言わない子
もう本当に辛くて
いやどうしたらいいかなと思っていたんですが
その子にも今の３つの質問
繰り返し繰り返し聞いていきました
で 小学校６年生の夏休みの前に
面談をしたときに
「今やってて楽しいことってある？」とか
「小学校最後６年生の夏だし
やりたいことありますか？」って
質問をしたときに
「友達と服を買いに行きたい」
ぼそっと言ってくれました
それでお母さんに頼んで
服を買いに行かせてもらった
というのがあります
で その年の冬
また次の面談があったときに
「じゃあファッションの関係とかってどう？」
という話をしていって
例えばファッションに関係する仕事といっても
例えばモデルになるとか
あとは 雑誌の編集者とか
あとは 服を売る人 アパレル関係とか
全部ファッションに関連する仕事だけど
「どんなのが興味ありそう？」って言うと
「ちょっとモデルに興味ありそう」って言う
で 「じゃあモデルになろう」って言って
でもモデルのなり方
ちょっとよくわかんなかったので
「じゃあ自分で調べてみてよ」って言って
調べてもらいました
その次 面談したときに
「先生 私 芸能事務所に
入ってるんです」って言われたんです
びっくりして 「え？」ってなって
もうすごく鳥肌たったんですが
今でもあの時のこと忘れないくらい
すごかったですね
で この間 面談したときに
最後にお母様が言ってくれたのが
高校生になったら
ちょっとずつ芸能活動を
本格的にやっていこうかなっていう
話をしてくれて
いま中学校１年生なんですが
お家で夢の話してくれてます
で 話をするときに使うアンケート
最初に書いてもらったものが
空欄だったんですが
今 書いてもらったアンケートには
将来について女優かモデルになりたい
理由も 読者モデルはいろんな可愛い服を着て
ってたくさん書いてくれています
自分の言葉で
自分の文字で書いてくれている
これが去年の夏休み前に書いてもらったもの
ここに書いてある
友達と遊ぶこととか服っていうのは
僕が面談をしながら書き足したものなので
提出してもらったときには 空欄でした
これが こうなるんです
夢が見つかるだけで
ここまで自分の文字にできるんだなと
夢の力をすごく感じました
ここまで 夢の話
たくさんしてきているんですが
こんな経験がきっかけになってると思います
３年前の２月に自分の親友が自殺しました
高校生からの仲だったので
もう何年も仲良くて
一緒に上京して ずっとつるんでた仲でした
最後に会ったのが
自殺の一週間前
全く前兆はなく
気づくことができなかった
今 考えてみても
なんでだろうな と思いますが
たくさん今までいろんなこと話してきたのに
将来の話 あんましたこと
なかったなって考えてます
彼にとって
大人になるイメージだったりだとか
この先の将来っていうのが
明確に見えてなかった
そんなふうに考えるようになりました
頭の良かったあいつにすら
見えなかった 将来
それを子供達と一緒に探していく
その想いから
自分の夢応援面談というものが
始まっていきました
この 「将来の夢ありますか？」という質問
ずっとずっと自分は繰り返しています
子供達と将来の夢を考える
夢応援面談を始めたときに
じゃあまず子供達から
見ようということで
「夢ありますか？」という
質問をしていったのですが
その途中で 気づくことがありました
そこは保護者との関係が
あまり良くないところもある
親の接し方が少し良くないところが
あるんじゃないか というものです
面談のスタートに
「将来の夢ありますか？」って聞くと
「あんまり考えてないよね？」って
保護者の方が口を挟むんです
これが多いんです
それにつられて 子供達は
「うん ない」って言ってしまう
これじゃあこの先考えられないんだろう
これじゃあ夢のことを考えられないし
どうやって過ごしていくのか
わかんなくなってしまう —
見失ってしまうんじゃないかなって思います
普通の道 …
普通の道と言ってもわからないですが
大学に進学して 就職をしていく
そのことしか考えられなくなってしまうん
じゃないかなと思ってます
僕の考えるのは
オトナの子供への接し方
ここに問題があると思っています
高校進学もそうですし
大学進学または大手企業への就職
そういうのは絶対じゃないと思ってます
塾やってる先生が 高校進学は絶対じゃない
なんて言うのはおかしいのですが
（笑）
絶対じゃないと思ってます
自分のなりたい夢 見つかって
そこに向けての道であれば
どんな道でもいい
そういうふうに本気で思っています
で 自分が子供と接するときには
ずっと考えていること
それは まず子供の心の中には
絶対に何かがある
絶対に将来の夢
絶対にあると思って考えています
それに加えて
その先 どんなに漠然とした夢であっても
いや 無茶だろうって夢であっても
「認める」っていうところです
絶対に否定はしない
ここで否定をしてしまうと
そこで 次の夢が途絶えてしまいます
「将来の夢？」
「うん 幸せになりたい」
と言ってくる子います
（笑）
さっき言った 漠然とした夢ですね
で この子に「将来の夢 何？」と言って
「幸せになりたい」と言われたので
「幸せってなんだろうね」と言うと
う〜ん 例えば大金持ちになるとか
あとは 大家族を持つとか
あとは 美味しいもの食べたいとか
（笑）
そんなんでも夢なんです
もう職業なんかじゃなくていい
夢なんてなんでもいいと思います
これこそが この子の
生きる意味であればいいかな
そういう風に僕は考えています
この先 この子たちが前を向いて生きる
そのために 将来の夢が少しでも役立てばいい
そう考えてます
で 僕がこんな風に毎日毎日
子供達と 「将来の夢なに？」
「将来の夢なに？」
「考えているのなに？」「次どうするの？」
という話をしているので
今度は子供達の方が
「先生 次はねこんな夢持ってるんだよね」
って話してくれるんです
もうどんどん どんどん毎日出てきます
でやっぱり 中学校とか高校生なので
自分の将来の夢って語るの難しいかな
っていう年代の子たちなんですが
言葉にしてくれます
さらに 僕に言葉をかけてくれるので
他の友達も聴いてる
「え お前それになるの！？」とか
本当に友達に聞かれてもいいような
そんな感覚でみんな話してくれるんです
みんな口に出して
それを さっき言った 認める
それを友達同士でやってます
これこそが
前を向いて生きていく理由に
なるんじゃないのかなと思っています
さっきのこの３つの質問
「夢はありますか？」の質問
「昔はあった？」
「今ハマっているものはなんですか？」
このたった３つの質問だけで
子供の中から何かが出てきます
それを 絶対に潰してほしくない
そこから対話をスタートしてほしい
認めること
それだけやってもらえれば十分です
それが 僕の今日お話ししたかった
夢応援面談の全貌です
ありがとうございました
（拍手）